sir I'm going to start with a big
congratulation oh man I'm sure it's
amazing Fight Club Baby Let's Do It
um thank I'm glad you noticed or knew
what it was some people have no idea
um so this is definitely the beginning
of you directing more movies because you
clearly know what you're doing so I am
I'm just going to start right from the
beginning uh are you already thinking
about what you want to do next is there
another genre that you want to play in
uh in terms of being behind the camera
yeah a little bit you know I'm playing
around with a couple a couple um genres
that that I like that I that interests
me
um not sure which way I want to go yet
but but there's a few or people already
offering you gigs phones ringed a couple
times which is which is like shocking
and and uh but but also you know you
know you know very humbling you know as
well and and you know what I guess the
work is speaking for itself so that's
pretty cool well it's gonna be it's
gonna be interesting for you because you
are going to be offered projects as an
actor because people want you to be
acting in their gigs and then also they
want you directing this had to have been
a very big challenge being obviously in
front of the camera doing boxing
sequence I mean you you bit off a lot
the next time that you direct will you
put yourself on camera in the movie or
I'm not sure about that I think that's
that's that's that's part of the like
the thought process is figuring out like
where what side of the land line you
want to stand on you know and it is the
project worth doing both you know um
just knowing what it takes out of you
you know like you know this took a piece
of me you know and and on all the best
ways but you know just to be able to
take it from you know pre-production to
to this day to today uh it's a lot in
this Relentless and you have to obsess
over and that's that's all you can focus
on so that level of commitment only can
come to a project that it's worthy you
know of that so so I just gotta you know
figure that out so Creed Rocky movies
the big things are the Montage sequence
and the third act fight and how you want
to shoot that so which one gave you more
nightmares at night thinking about was
it the the training montage
monetize because
I put myself into a corner because I
the way we built Damien you know um as a
character by the time we got to the
Montage you know you know we had to
figure out ways to whoa the mod how we
want people to feel going into that
final you know that final fight is you
know you you know you don't we Donna
said to feel like an underdog you know
so so it the the the scale had to be
almost a skewed the other way a little
bit where you had some doubt and you
wasn't sure if our hero was going to
make make you know make it through and
that balance in a montage and figuring
out the right things to hit and what
does adonis need to go through this
Montage so he can become the best
version of himself in that fight so he
can be prepared to fight Damien was a
challenge for sure and all the visuals
and you know the you know the flashy
stuff and stuff that looks cool or
whatever is great but getting to like
the Crux of what this Montage really
means was was a was a challenge and I
think we worked it out I'm fascinated by
the editing process and I'm just curious
how did the film change in the editing
room in ways that you were not expecting
I think you know I have phenomenal
editors you know Tyler and Jess you know
they're they're they're they're they're
they're they're they're truly truly
helpful and you know you know and you
know and detrimental and you know Mike
shawver as well in in this editing
process and at the the reality of you
write one movie you shoot Moon movie and
you edit one movie I know what that
means now you know and you know the
movie's going to tell you what it needs
you know and what it and what it's
becoming so certain scenes that I really
really you know wanted to make the film
you know in a real way you know some
some of them aren't in the movie you
know and they're they're on the
editorial floor because the movie told
me that it needed to be something else
so I think you know the editing process
for me was um was a real master class at
really listening to the to the film you
know listening to the characters
regardless of what I set out to shoot in
the beginning you know it's going to
tell you what it needs to be and and um
and that's what happened